foreign
if you want to have kids then you need
to know about this chart it shows the
number of follicles that a woman has
follicles usually contain eggs and start
from a peak of over a million before
she's even been born
to just a few hundred by her late 40s
this and a drop in egg quality mean it's
harder for women to get pregnant from
their mid-30s
which is a problem as across the rich
world people are trying to start
families later
and one in six couples now struggle to
get pregnant
age-related infertility is one of the
biggest challenges for the fertility
sector today
[Music]
so what's the answer freezing your eggs
may seem like a good way to delay having
children can women really take fertility
into their own hands via egg freezing
we're a little afraid that people who
freeze at an unknown entity at a new lab
might come back in 10 years and their
success isn't what they thought it would
be
or could jaw-dropping scientific
advances do away with the need for human
ovaries altogether
it has this potential to actually be
able to create entirely new Exiles for
people that don't otherwise have
fertility options right now
Deborah is going through in vitro
fertilization or IVF
find my stuff I have like my
subcutaneous injection pins she
struggled to get pregnant in the past
and is now trying for her third child
I think my age really played into
wanting to do um wanting to do more IVF
I'm 37 and I kind of saw this as like my
last window to possibly be able to go in
and create a few more embryos
for each cycle she injects herself with
hormones to stimulate her ovaries to
produce as many mature eggs as possible
these are then extracted and fertilized
in the lab by mixing them with sperm or
injecting sperm directly into the egg
it's physically and emotionally
challenging
I'm not good with the hormone side
effects I end up getting really moody
and really sad personally I find it to
be a very unpleasant experience
despite the live reality of IVF the
market for assisted reproductive
technology is booming it's estimated to
be worth around 20 billion dollars and
Counting
here in the US it's a very high margin
sector you see a lot of private Equity
money going into the sector because of
that they also like it because it's
relatively likely regulated compared to
other parts of medicine demand is
growing
um and there is a lot of unfulfilled
demand out there Ergo there's a lot to
sell
much of this demand is coming from
people who like Deborah and her partner
are trying to conceive later in life
when they're up against their biological
clock the trouble is IVF is an imperfect
technology for age-related infertility
although success rates have improved
dramatically in the past 30 years on
average in Britain 38 year old women
still have less than a 20 chance of
having a baby after one Embryo transfer
and progress across the board has
largely stalled
I would say it's a sector that despite
all the froth and excitement is actually
pretty stuck at the moment
[Music]
to understand why we need to go back to
the 1970s when this remarkable footage
of the first IVF baby shocked the world
okay this in pretty good condition the
first IVF baby was Louise Brown she was
the daughter of Leslie Brown
Leslie Brown had blocked fallopian tubes
IVF was first invented to help women
with mechanical reasons for infertility
it wasn't designed to improve uravarian
reserve it wasn't designed to improve
egg quality in it and it still can do
neither of those things in a sense we're
using the wrong tool to address the
infertility crisis
so if IVF can't beat the biological
clock then what can
well one solution that seems to be
everywhere in the media is egg freezing
egg freezing egg freezing
you're sort of stopping the clock on as
many eggs as you can and then coming
back to them later
M was in her late 20s when she started
looking into fertility preservation
I had essentially been single for a
while and I had heard about egg freezing
and I thought I would start saving
towards it
this doesn't come cheap
in America a woman can spend 30 to 40
000 on two cycles of freezing and
Storage
in the UK where M lives costs are lower
but it still took years of saving before
she could go ahead I wanted to
gift my My Future Self my older self my
younger eggs she's far from alone in
taking this step
in Britain the annual number of egg
freezing Cycles carried out with the
intention of use by patients increased
tenfold between 2009 and 2019 while it
fell slightly during the pandemic it
Rose sharply in 2021
but this still represents a tiny number
of women relative to the UK population
there's been more growth in America
thanks in part to employers subsidizing
treatment
you see quite a lot of growth for two
reasons really partly more types of
employers who are making this part of
their benefit and package I think it's
also partly just awareness slowly but
surely the evidence around its relative
Effectiveness is becoming more solid
in a good lab around 90 of eggs can
survive freezing and thawing and it's
clearer how many eggs a woman needs to
freeze for a chance of getting pregnant
according to the largest U.S study on
this so far 70 percent of women who
first froze their eggs when they were
under 38 and then thawed at least 20 of
them went on to have a baby
but even then success is never
guaranteed
as well as trying for a baby Deborah and
her husband Jake run a website fertility
IQ which helps people navigate the
fertility Market including egg freezing
soar egg freezing courses probably our
most popular course we've seen a
dramatic change in the demographics of
the people that come to take the course
the trend is for people to come younger
but they fear the increased demand and
profitability of egg freezing means some
clinics are overselling the chance of
success
the quality of the clinic in many ways
is going to determine the odds that it
works there are so many startups now in
the space but the reality of what's
going on behind the scenes in that lab
is really unknown and so we're a little
afraid that people who freeze at an
unknown entity at a new lab might come
back in 10 years and have a really
terrible surprise that their success
isn't what they thought it would be
when M throws her eggs she was surprised
how little information was available
the doctors don't tell you
look if you go into egg retrieval
you might not get the numbers that you
want and when her first retrieval didn't
go as well as she hoped she was
devastated
I thought I'm so young to have
what I thought was like a failed attempt
I thought I'm gonna have to do this
another two times and where I'm like
where am I gonna get that money from I
don't want to have to inject
I do this whole process again
medically it's the same as going through
an IVF cycle except for the last bit
fertilizing the egg and then placing it
um in your womb it's a physically taxing
thing to go through
M did eventually freeze her eggs
successfully but some researchers have
started to wonder if there's a better
way of doing things perhaps by taking
ovaries out of the baby making equation
altogether
[Music]
The Economist environment editor if
you'd like to read more of our coverage
of fertility and women's health issues
why not take out a subscription to The
Economist you'll receive daily and
weekly analysis of global Affairs and
you can read us online in the app and
you'll receive the audio Edition as well
and for the best offer please click the
link
this is Dr Hayashi katsuhiko the seven
years ago he made Headlines by
announcing he'd grown egg cells or o
sites from mice in the lab without
needing an ovary at all
when I saw the fast result of the the
outside production in culture we are so
much excited
Hayashi and his team used a technique
called in vitro gametogenesis or ivg
to make the eggs the Japanese team took
skin cells from a mouse's tail and using
a cocktail of chemicals nudged them into
becoming pluripotent stem cells
a special type of cell that can develop
into many different types of tissue
these stem cells were then further
nudged into becoming o sites which were
fertilized to create baby mice
perfecting the process took 10 years
the first time I got the baby from such
a impediment outside was it's just
amazing just amazing
Dr hayashi's team then took this one
step further by growing egg cells using
stem cells from male mice creating in
effect mice with two dads
[Music]
their work has caught the attention of
the Silicon Valley entrepreneur who's
excited about the possibilities of this
new tech I myself am gay and something
I'm very personally interested in in
terms of how it could allow people like
me to be able to have biological
children with their partners
Matt chriseloff who is a founding member
of openai is so invested in the promise
of ivg that he set up a company
conception to try to develop Dr
hayashi's work into humans it has this
potential to actually be able to create
entirely new Exiles for people that
don't otherwise have fertility options
right now so thank women in their 40s or
50s potentially same-sex couples or say
cancer patients as well that have had
their eggs wiped out by chemotherapy if
you look at the spikiness is it
irregular yes
but it's actually not a problem
Matt says his team hoped to produce
proof of concept human eggs within a
year
and that this could be just the
beginning
if you can really take a scanner blood
sample and turn these into eggs that
could be a lot better than the
traditional IVF experience which
requires hormone injections and a
surgical procedure to take out the eggs
honestly I can even imagine a scenario
down the line where mainstream people
may want to have this technologist the
way they have children just in the sense
that it could allow for much more
genetic screening for disease purposes
but there are many safety concerns to
address before eggs grown in a lab via
ivg could be used in fertility treatment
the longer embryos remain in the dish
outside a woman's body the more tiny
minute changes there are to that embryo
which do not mimic the natural process
in ivg there's a protracted period of
out of body manipulation and I think all
of that generates concerns about safety
the viability of those cells
the lab-grown eggs have so far also had
a very low success rate for producing
baby mice
but even if ivg is never safe enough to
be used in humans as fertility treatment
it could still help move the dial and
Research into how to make babies
if nothing else what you're doing is
creating a readily available stock of
eggs for people to do research on and
understand that basic science of human
reproduction which is currently so
difficult to do in part because not that
many women donate their eggs just to
research and so it enables research that
up until now has been very difficult
not content with growing eggs in a lab
Dr Hayashi is now researching ways to
stop a woman's biological clock
altogether
using a protein that occurs naturally in
cells called cohesion
people believe that we are those kind of
decrease of the cohesion is one of the
reason why aged people cannot get the
baby
the idea is that if you can understand
why immature eggs age
then can you stop some aging could you
potentially give women a pill that would
freeze her ovarian reserve in her
twenties so that at some point when she
wanted to become pregnant the eggs that
were in her ovaries in ovarian reserve
at that point would not be 40 year old
eggs but would in fact be say 25 year
old eggs
[Music]
despite the promise of This research it
will be a very long time before this is
anywhere near a reality
just trying to beat the biological clock
there is at least the hope that perhaps
future Generations will be making babies
in entirely new ways and later in life
[Music]
please click the link thank you for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
foreign